what do you think about canelo and this  guy cap caleb caleb kelly plant calendar  talking [ __ ]  you know what i think that um kayla  possessed the skills to beat canelo i  just don't know if caleb can withstand  the  punches  cause i think in order to beat canelo  you got to be able to outbox you got to  be able to hurt him you got to be able  to make a respect if you can't hurt him  it's over there yeah it's okay he's  going to walk right through you yeah so  i think he was just excused but i don't  know  if he was just the power to hurt him or  to withstand his i know he's gonna use  those skills he's gonna miss some  punches he's gonna feel the [ __ ] one  of those punches that he missed and he's  gonna say [ __ ] i'm gonna get out of this  [ __ ]  he's like  get out of this [ __ ]  [Music]